do you see can you guess without just
looking what is that
i did that for you
pokemon snap oh no that's ocarina of
time
it's the woods yeah
blurry in three seconds
um i've been playing it with this it
would have been way easier but i
couldn't recognize the words immediately
no you did great also yeah i've showed
you this right like i've been playing
this guy
um and i never played link's awakening
yeah for the audio listeners troy what
did you just hold up to camera oh sorry
sorry sorry i always forget you guys you
wonderful people i love there's so many
comments from a spot of like this
doesn't make any sense and then the
second comment was i just want to point
out that i'm listening on spotify
i was like we are a visual medium um i i
just held up and i love giving this guy
props at hungrybartender on instagram is
my buddy eric castro if you're a best
friend you're familiar with him he's an
incredible bartender and he just
recently lost um his his furry friend
um that he loved lily um a wonderful
beautiful little dog shout out to lily
yeah and so he decided
uh to to turn that frown upside down so
to speak and he
he's got a fascinating uh he's got a
fascination and a love
for all things analog especially when it
comes to like uh game stuff so he like
restores old crt monitors um and he
rebuilds game boys and so i saw this was
like dude i gotta get one he's like
anybody that buys this all the money is
going towards this charity and i was
like take my money and so he built me
this he was like i got this really cool
electric blue one that i think you would
dig it's really nice it's super cool
gorgeous like i kind of want to i kind
of want one of these that looks amazing
i i i feel like i'm going to inundate
him because it's a side project so this
is not like what he does professionally
but i've really given a lot of shout
outs i'm afraid people will be like
build me one he's like god i don't have
this is the problem when you do a nice
thing for troy is he wants to celebrate
your father yeah man they knock your
door down he's so cool but it is you
need like a thousand hours of work yeah
it's a lot like
he he he put some time into this
and i have it has brought me so much joy
i put up on instagram the other day that
i i remember on a family trip with my
dad
i played with the original dot matrix
screen this one's backlit which you
could buy the backlit screen but it
drained your battery um
i didn't own a game boy
i just had to borrow my friends and my
friend stephen kirkenbauer who had one
was like here
actually no it wouldn't have been steve
i wouldn't even met him yet some other
random friend i remember but i said i'm
going on a trip can i borrow this so i
had like three days with this thing
and i never was able to beat um
super mario land and i remember the way
that i felt when i saw
jesus christ for the audio listeners
all right well maybe let's see who lasts
longer on this one
um i'm sorry and uncomfortable whoever
wins
that's why your audio sounds so bad
he's wearing his bane
i scare you so i i remember the the the
batteries draining and and holding on as
it just like was was faded dot matrix uh
and the last glimmer of of visuals faded
with the last drop of battery and that
was the last time i played that game and
that was 32 years ago so i was like 12
maybe 13. battery is a good unit of
measure drops that's the actual
scientific measure and as you all know
we are scientists
um
so i i had to get the game boy back and
i never had one and pam didn't even know
this was like this is this is the first
game boy that i've ever owned like i i
never
i never had an advance i've never had an
sp the first console
that i bought was a playstation one like
with my own money because i never had
one growing up i would go over to my
friend's house or i would uh rent one or
whatever but the first actual
uh console that i bought was a
playstation one
and played the [ __ ] out of those games
and then playstation 2 immediately
because it was finally cheap i was like
why is this so cheap it's because the
ps2 is about to drop so then i got a ps2
ps3 and
onwards but
man i've had so much fun just sitting
here playing like all of these old
classic games
so well made i
really are high school used to play game
boy by hiding it inside of my pencil
case so i would be playing game boy
games large pencil cases they were huge
yeah it's very inefficient but that's
how i was i was playing it all through
high school i had a great time uh but i
also want to chat you guys know who
anthony carboni is from the star wars
show tonight
he
he does
game boy stuff sometimes twitter like
similar to that i waited till the end of
your story oh that's awesome
i forgot that i had shaved also that's
yeah that wasn't intentionally part of
the drama austin when tory is freshly
shorn all the way all the way oh no
never never never never
no no no no
that's not what you're doing thank you
mike
please continue your pencil case story
no uh so it's going to be a family show
you thought wrong um
also
i don't i don't know what the right one
is modifies upgrades game boys and he i
always watch his instagram stories when
he posts the process
and the other day he was posting like oh
so i did this i replaced the screen i
got this new screen to get rid of all
the old scratches from this thing um and
then the next story is a hard cut to it
being shattered
and i completely unexpectedly and he's
like and then i accidentally like pushed
it too hard while cleaning it and
shattered it it was after these like
five really informative stories of like
oh interesting cool and then it's just a
little one-act play
yes absolutely
the failures yeah yeah did you
alana i feel like you always had
your parents loved you more um i do feel
like i had quite loving parents yes well
you just always had like the thing like
you you gaming is gaming has been a part
of my life but i had it because my dad
sold computers
and so i grew up playing pcs and so i i
would you know
pirate
the games off of my friend he's like you
got to play this game and he would copy
that onto three to five
three and a half or five inch disc
drives that's how i put that in there
that's how i had spear of destiny i had
like 17 floppy discs
uh that uh that compiled that game
but i didn't have a concert can i throw
in the fact
go how big how how large
and what's the sorry what's the diameter
of the disc of a three and a half inch
floppy one inch
no [ __ ]
i don't know it's nearly three and a
half inches the reason being that
they're the i think they're the one
major disc format this is so nerdy that
was made in japan so they're metroid so
they crucially they're in centimeters
not inches
so when they were when they were
localized to like american and british
audiences they they put that but it's
not quite the right measurement so
there's a spec it's whatever the nearest
sense meter is no we also just saw how
stupid i am the name is literally in the
title of it and i went a couple i
thought yeah
no but i had the same thought i thought
i thought it was going to be one of
those little q it's like a half or
something is what i expected yeah they
labeled it based on the exterior casing
not the actual was it five and a quarter
and three and a half is that what it was
five and a quarter three and a half
that's not all right
what was it in the metrics it's five and
something i mean by the time i was using
it was three intentionally right for a
living
i don't it's all fine i have been trying
to go through and find younger viewers
three and a half inches is the it's the
disc that is the now the save icon it is
which you don't understand what that
weird rectangle is that's what i still
had floppy disks when i was in school
but i had been yeah we just they were
just being phased out um i've been
trying to go through and buy my favorite
game because i there's no point in
owning physical games anymore
don't have space this is my issue i used
to collect all of them i had almost
every xbox 360 game almost every n64
game and then i was like what do i do
with all this [ __ ] when i moved to
countries it became very pointless so
i'm trying to just buy
physical uh copies of my favorite game
every year and uh my favorite game 1993
which is the year i was born is doom
the first doom is still in my top five
games of all time i absolutely love doom
um and i it's actually not that hard to
still find the original floppies that
doom came on
shockingly it was massive wasn't it it
was like a culture as long as it was the
gta of its day like it broke out beyond
for sure it changed everything everyone
had that for sure because it was also
synonymous with like cult cultural rot
and
depravity and stuff because it was so
violent and all the people that were
skeptical of their kids playing video
games and corrupted as a result right
now all four of us have failed in life
because we played video games at a young
age yeah but there was like especially
with a kid growing up in church do you
think i was i was allowed to play doom
the first second that anybody was like
that's a pentagram so this is basically
how you're like hi satan would you like
to come and live in my heart like
whatever the opposite of the sinner's
prayer is doom was you know what i mean
yeah it's like i i think i'm sure i
would have said this before but i got
into video games
um
because and to the my parents loved
loving me and giving me stuff i had an
n64 growing up second hand two years
after it came out it was my first access
to something um
i know we actually
had very little money uh i remember
trying to buy a bike one year and it
didn't we couldn't afford it it was
devastating i had to stop doing
triathlons um in any case
uh the
the most of my gaming was from the
cereal boxes that came with demos so i
played a lot of age of empires but it
was the cd roms wait a minute a lot of
age of empires america
living in america sucked what you guys
didn't get that did you not have games
on cereal boxes in america really i
don't remember that i now keep demos
they weren't like full versions was this
like did you get the on brand cereals or
were you getting like the store brand
version of the same thing like it wasn't
fruity pebbles it was like i don't have
all these stupid cereals [ __ ]
ridiculous cereal brands i've been
meaning to make a video where i try to
guess if something's a street drug or a
american cereal brand for a really long
time because they're all [ __ ]
ridiculous that would be fantastic
games on the front of cereal boxes that
was the whole thing no no
no these toys you dug through
there was this stale and then you got
you got a thing out that broke in six
seconds and even that was pretty much on
its way out mario was on the box
that's how i got age of empires so i was
stuck playing this demo on repeat for a
really long time but as a kid i didn't
know um and i didn't care but otherwise
my mum had found a bunch of educational
games which i feel like is very
progressive for her time as someone who
doesn't know anything about any kind of
tech so that's what really started me
gaming was that she found a bunch of
like maths and writing games and there
was a um a mario game that's about
typing
uh i don't know what it's called but all
this educational stuff that i started
playing as a kid that like what's the
one was it word math rescue word rescue
where you like got picked up by like a
caterpillar with an umbrella or
something and i remember playing that
like on a little i think that was like
an apogee one of the maths ones that i
played
there was this one character that would
say we like our eggs scrambled but i
don't know what the game is that that
came from burned into my fridge boy was
that voiceover
tell us the story of its production
because it was non-union
i definitely have vivid memories of some
encyclopedia britannica game
that was like escape amazed by you know
learning history or whatever yeah
encyclopedia
the church one i had all the church ones
there were church video games oh my god
oh so oh that's a whole sub genre really
to this day they're still making him and
it's like yeah okay you're you get to
play as jesus and you get to multiply
fishes how many fishes do you need to
feed the five thousands uh
like there are like like tall tale style
like and quality bar games about like
bible stories and stuff no
man i don't know like americans keep
buying them people are going to make
them for sure like that's traveler
traveler gets to like so
love her parents jump on this bandwagon
but uh
traveler if if uh if he goes poop
uh which he does quite often great news
very good that's i mean we're all glad
to hear yeah that's like hey man if you
want to chill out your parents that's
what i always say that's situation
that's how we know we're doing well
um as you're saying [ __ ] today yes he is
well done
um that's all i gotta do keep him alive
and make him [ __ ] so yeah he gets to
watch a little bit it's pretty much the
standard we hold ourselves to and it's
true
he gets like a tv reward for
successfully yeah delivering the package
everyone everyone who reached out to
mike bithell this week on the comments
uh we want to let you know mike's doing
well he's [ __ ]
he's doing with regularity he's doing
great regularity
um so anyway traveler gets to watch uh a
little bit of tv and like right now
he's into uh there's some great equality
education um there's this guy that's in
um
canada called brain candy and he
it's just awesome he's it's really well
done he's enthusiastic and he's got this
joy of like getting kids to to learn and
have a passion for learning early so get
to watch that and then every once while
youtube goes what about this [ __ ] mom
and dad and we don't have a chance to go
oh [ __ ] and get off of it and so it this
one was called raising little ones for
jesus and i was like hmm all right let's
let's watch this one it's like stick
around after the after the show that
we're doing gonna do an unboxing video
of something for for another message and
i was like
are we are we at the point where we were
doing that like
three years old so to to the point of
giving kids games on cereal boxes talk
about knowing your demographic
yeah
well it's also great because if i
remember ryan i don't know if you if you
agree with this a lot but they were also
kind of they weren't actually games that
were suitable for demographic they were
like age of empires or they were like
there were a lot of like strategy games
and things that maybe you've got no
you're right they weren't kids games so
they weren't kids games well it was
great because it broadened my horizons
like i remember playing those games and
playing games i would never have like
thought to pick up as a dumb kid but
like you'd get into like an age of
empires and you just play the demo on
the loop like a longer sentence and
you'd
is that though do you think that is
something
for like who who who partners that deal
between like
stay 100 is the story right like
100 the humble bundle of its day so
there's definitely when you make and
sell a game like you know you're gonna
make most of your money kind of very
early on in terms of like your full
price offering okay like most people
don't buy a game full price six months
after the launch of that game right
into your sales right but but on on for
for the purposes of this do you know if
the game was
already out and this was a sampling of
that so i think that's what i'm saying
is i think this was after the fact so i
think what you do is you know you've got
your launch window then you've got now
you've got like sale discount window but
back then there was no online store so
probably there wasn't
so at that point like you know six
months a year after release i imagine
the serial company went and just did
like we'll give you
50 grand 100 grand and you just have to
put a demo on the box and it has to be
like a substantial enough demo that our
audience likes it and
i'm sure in most cases people like yeah
sure like have it that you're not gonna
put like
you don't have mario 64 on there because
you're still selling that every day over
and over but like yeah like a an out of
date strategy game that you know you've
already sold to your core audience and
then what you're doing and i'm
you know i'm sure some of these
publishers were that smart you're also
getting kids into a thing where there's
still age of empires games coming out
right like and that's to
some percentage of that audience will be
the kids like me and alana who got the
the cd rom on the box so it's a
generational thing exactly same reason
microsoft when it buys minecraft isn't
worrying about the players who are
playing minecraft then they're investing
in 20 years from now when those kids
have kids and will want to play
minecraft with their own kids so what's
your corollary to now like what would
you say is is that thing now humble
bundle game pass
oh humble bundle yeah
game pass like if i've got an old game
or and i'm you know ps plus or game plus
kind of come to me and say we'll give
you this lump sum to be in there if i
know that that game
again like these things are pretty
predictable like after a certain point
like you've made your sales at launch
and you know okay if i do a discount on
this specific store i will make this
much a day and it's pretty you know
pretty standard like there's there's
wobble based on like if you're on the
front page of the store or whatever but
generally like you know what where
you're at and if someone comes to you
and goes well we'll give you this lump
sum but then you know theoretically no
one's gonna buy your game on xbox
anymore you can do that some and go okay
so if i put this in game pass and it
stops selling on xbox am i gonna lose am
i gonna make more than on that one-time
deal than i would make over the next
three years selling it in sales on xbox
and that sum gets done and that's why a
game goes on game boss is that a is it
the developers think that number is
bigger is that like i don't think i'm
going to do well but with this i can or
is it or do you build that into your
marketing strategy or your site it's
definitely lower risk it's lower risk
but there's very few games
there's very few games that like do
really good business years after the
fact like of our games like thomas was
alone is the one that like still sells
lots of copies but like most games have
like a shelf life rocket league launched
on um
playstation plus uh games with whatever
i don't remember what the term is and i
worked there um so it was free and
that's the reason why uh rocket league
took off and is now incredibly
successful but funnily enough has gone
full circle to now being free to play as
well
but rocket league and that's the thing
is you can sometimes play that so you
can go we're going to put it free on
this platform to get buzz but we're
going to charge every other platform for
it so you can do loads of weird things
yeah so yeah that's what he did with
john wick hex came out like in an as an
epic store exclusive
um on pc and had a lot like discounts
early on but then on other platforms it
didn't and that kind of fueled interest
and sales so yeah you can it's a whole
thing i was always also fascinated the
the kind of
the kind of um
similar but different concept of when
hardware will make a deal with a game
like every new gateway pc will come with
such and such demo of a game just
installed
zorg came packaged with gateway pcs i
played the [ __ ] out of that
so good and sometimes the developers
will like pay for that or ask for that
right like sometimes sometimes it's
gateway paying but sometimes it's free
advertising so you're like yeah sure i
discovered i remember i remember um
the lucas arts tim schaefer uh full
throttle was on a p i went into a store
that was like a
you know
i don't it wasn't a best buy but it was
a that kind of you know fries or
whatever
and i wandered over to the computer
section
and
uh they had that
like the demo of it installed on the
machine and it was like it was like
literally
a marketing strategy aimed squarely at
me because it was you know you can play
the first five minutes of this game
um
and uh and and you know as a
demonstration of how this computer works
like it was a it was a you know
come try out the the you know rpcs and
the way you try them out is by you know
the keyboard and mouse as facilitated by
this game and of course i was like
immediately going well how do i you know
you beat the demo in in moments and so
you're like
i got to keep going you know where it
instantly became a
tim schaefer acolyte
official like that's great for the game
it's great for the platform like i think
people often like games are a business
and of course the objective in the end
is to get paid so everyone can like pay
their bills but at the same time like
there are ways of getting value out of
something rather than money so like
there's definitely deals we've done
where we've not made enormous money from
it but we knew that we would get
exposure right we knew we'd get some
visibility out of it or something like
that you make those kind of decisions
all the time you know that altered beast
was a demo
like it was never meant to be a
an actual thing it was just showcasing
what uh
what that engine could do at the time
and that's why it's so short
um but it ended up becoming especially
for the sega genesis or the sega mega
drive depending upon where in the world
you grew up it became one of the most
you know iconic games for that console
generation but it had the same thing it
was like just throw this out there
uh i think jack actress to me is is
doing something very similar with erica
erica was never
you know it was their first offering as
a studio for flavor works but if you
haven't played erica by the way you
absolutely should i still haven't i
really i really do need to man the good
thing is is that yes
the composer's song you managed to get
over it you liked the you liked you
liked the bongos that's some cool
technique i just like the bombs
and erica yeah it's great
with the uh the tech in that game it's
really cool
yeah core engine is genuinely really
clever and especially for um playing it
on iphone or or ipad
um ipad is definitely the ideal yeah
it's bigger it's more cinematic
it was always
saying that publicly no it was always
conceived of as an ipad on playstation
austin
i think it's best on playstation i think
the rhony way to really experience it is
true vision austin was probably with
that dual shock uh four i believe well
they accept the ironic things you can
play
really
that's the funny thing that because it
was always my god i'll send you a check
later
sorry about it i like i i'm a point down
right though the spiel even when i'm
marketing
i'm also so separate from playstation
like i don't know i'm not doing it for
you i'm doing it because like that's
just the show no i appreciate the stuff
that you learned to say but it's i can't
wait for the comments to talk about how
we're such you know playstation fanboys
we got called shills last week for not
talking about death loop when the only
thing we said about death loop was
technically negative i was like how is
this chilly
i by the way
troy was talking about having troubles
installing it which after that
conversation a lot of other people have
stood by i also before we get to death
loop which i swear to god we will
because we we spoke about really still
haven't played it by the way austin
from the podcast um
i know i'm playing a 30 year old game
midnight mass comes out
on the 24th which means it's on the 23rd
um yeah i'm really curious to see what
you specifically think of it troy
because it is a really religious show
and i think it's fantastic uh loved it
but it it's so religious and i'm so
curious what what people with religious
uh backgrounds think if they if they
like it or find it insulting or i don't
know how it's gonna be taken i am
reading dude this is where i'm like
my whole focus right that sounds bad but
there's a there's a majority of the
things that i'm i love to consume books
and one of the main things that i'm
supposed to read them
oh [ __ ] that's why
i was like i'm not learning anything and
my tummy hurts
um but my son shits well so we're good
uh yeah the fibers
excellent in books i i went down this
kind of rabbit hole of of uh questioning
and pushing back against kind of the the
things that we've always especially
people grew up in the church just kind
of took as fact as opposed to going well
maybe this doesn't make so much sense uh
one of them is a book called zealot that
was referred to me by or recommended to
me by jeffrey pearce
who played tommy in the last of us and
he's an avid reader he's a voracious
reader and he said i think you would
enjoy this book and i did and then i
started reading uh misinterpreting
scripture through western eyes which was
a really cool
understanding of like most people don't
look at the context of of when quote
scripture was written and then that led
to this book by this wonderful woman i
can't remember her name right now but um
it's called uh the origin of satan and
just learning about where that whole
idea came from and how it's such a
modern creation
because it's not in the book
right idea
satan isn't mentioned it's satan in the
copy of the bible it's like it's
translated a couple of times yeah but i
mean you have to look at it there's the
evil one or the bad guys satan just
means adversary but satan is referred to
as as
the the bible that we have is just so
modern compared to the origin of those
thoughts and precepts uh hundreds of
years later uh after
a lot of political um
a lot of political upheaval in war
uh and people going we can make multiple
translations and yeah anyone who's put
things through google translate knows
like once you've taken original
scripture put it into what was the what
was the journey of the king james it's
like greek well then and that's so funny
like a few different
these are people that were illiterate
that spoke aramaic and then they were
occupied by rome so they learned the
educated learned greek and so then they
were written in greek which is not their
native language and then greek got
translated to latin latin into german
german and then it comes across to
england so it's just like yeah it was
like there's not a word for this um
there's well also adding to that that
there isn't a single original manuscript
anyway uh right and the book of mark was
not written by mark it was
a compendium of stories of people
spoilers troy sorry
2000 years if you haven't read it by now
i haven't read it yet um it's not and i
i never i always grew up
mark sat down and was like here's my you
know here's my memoirs i remember
walking along with jesus i was like no
not at all it's like these are hundreds
of years later uh the earliest one is
like 180 and
the same time marcus aurelius was
writing meditations a bunch of people
were going do you remember the stories
that john and people have told through
the centuries about this and like yeah
but i believe it was more this and so
they had to agree on a consensus and
then 200 years after that people agreed
on a consensus and we continue to do
that
there's a really good talk about death
loop
i'll just add one sentence in the same
vein you've lost a lot of chunky
audience already yeah i i listened uh to
an audio book uh by a guy named bart
ehrman called lost christianities which
was also on the same topic of
talking through all the various sects
that didn't survive
and how wildly different they are from
anything
resembling what we would call
christianity today i mean fully
polytheistic variants of christianity
and things that are almost
that almost have that kind of um
that have that polytheism track with
something called literally christianity
like surely the the mono fear stick is
baked
but then you start looking at father son
holy spirit and that was also
yeah but there's more to it than that
also because there's you know the
i wish i i wish i you know had memorized
the book it was like i had it as an
audio book and it was like it's like 20
hours or something like that so i would
listen to it over the course of about a
month while i walked with a dog
um but just the thing the biggest
impression that it it left me with was
just
you know how you remember how in like da
vinci code
the the the kind of twist is that
they're like this they're like this very
kind of almost sex cult
uh uh kind of uh
underground society that's the kind of
[ __ ] where you go back far enough in
some of these other lost variants of
christianity that's basically
there's there were there were variants
like that wow you know that that are you
know super sort of hedonistic and
thought that's the path to
worship and all these sorts of things
and he he goes through them and and you
know some of them some of them the the
fragments of the record of them is so
minimal also that very little is known
and it's fascinating to think there were
you know thousands or hundreds of
thousands or maybe even millions of
people that live their whole life
dedicated to a belief system that now we
have half a page that's written that's
ripped that was found in some library in
like
rome that someone didn't realize was in
the library until someone found it by
mistake and that's the only remaining
record of like how millions of people
live their lives 1500 years ago or
something like that and it's just the
bishop well some of that's fraudulent
the bishop well that's the other big
challenge how did you get written by
their enemies right yeah but like one of
the leaders he talks a lot about that
too one of the leaders of the early
church first went
i don't think jesus ever said that he
was god and that guy became an apostate
and they said all right hands up was he
god or not and the eyes won it and that
was in 325 and that guy was like you're
now out excommunicated all of the good
that he did didn't matter anymore he was
a bad guy and he was kicked out all of
that said i appreciate anybody who hung
in i love talking about this stuff
do your research just
if nothing else these conversations what
i love about them is that every single
time i learn something from this and
it's only because i'm willing to go i
learned nothing whenever i said yeah i
know what that is it's only until i went
i don't know what that is mike can you
show that to me austin can you share
that with me alana what does that mean
and i've just become more fascinated
with learning and and showing what i
don't know than what i do know
i think that comes with age that's
that's the thing that like you know when
you i said this on twitter the other day
when i was 15 i thought i knew
everything and now every year i realized
how little i know year by year i'm like
i don't know [ __ ] i don't know [ __ ] i
don't know [ __ ] when i was 15 i was like
that's also the path to wisdom
like not knowing is yeah knowing knowing
what you don't know or knowing that you
don't know and you'll never know is such
a path to like just maturity i think
plus i i remember as a kid you know in
the classroom there's definitely that
feeling of
you know
you know does anybody not understand
what i'm talking about from the teacher
and you feel a lot of pressure to not be
the one that is true there's a certain
amount of and then every now and again
there'd be that one kid who goes i don't
get it and 17 others would go oh yeah me
either and and it was like
you know that kid's doing it right all
the rest you need to get over this
hurdle but we can't as a social species
it's really hard to be the one who
raises their hand dude tom hanks shows
the weakness tom hanks and big exactly
what you're talking about when i saw
that in that movie when he plays the you
know josh baskin he's sitting there in
the meeting he's like
i don't get it
sorry is i i don't get it
the building that becomes a robot
i don't get it that exactly we're
talking was like oh man maybe that's the
thing was like you become the hero when
you go i don't get it can you please
explain it to me like i'm the person
you're making this for and i don't get
it
that to me
is the point and alana i would say that
that's
that's one part of it but you do know
[ __ ]
yeah sure i mean i have i have like i'm
not trying to dismiss the little pockets
of knowledge that i do have but um it's
those last expanses i i think that it's
okay being it's like i know this but
there's more to learn to me that's
that's the next thing it's like going
from i know everything to i don't know
[ __ ] to i do know some things but i want
to know more like that to me is a
is maybe even the evolution that i've or
the the path at least that i've been on
i hate that journey i hate that [ __ ]
yeah
also a bad composer
yeah you owe me money if you do yeah i
thought it would be steve perry money if
i said that
i i i the way i've always looked at it
is that there's sort of three categories
of information the
the things you know the things that you
know you don't know and the things that
you don't know you don't know true and i
the way to me rumsfeld the media yes
exactly the unknown unknowns i uh i
think that the arc the that sort of path
to wisdom is
as the knowns grows slowly
the
ideal is that the unknown unknowns
shrinks rapidly because you you
basically are adding to the list of
things that you have just enough
exposure to to realize you don't know
those things which is why you're always
getting that
overwhelming feeling of every year that
goes by i'm more aware of kind of how
far the horizon goes
you know than relative to the year
before well that's the theory have you
heard the theory that the reason your
life feels like it's passing faster as
you age
is because you know more have you heard
this like basically i just watched a
video about this less than a week ago i
have thought i'm so good
correct me when i go wrong on this
ethereum
so it's the idea
it's your brain so your brain's a
computer okay right so you're so if you
think about um uh how computers work
like what what causes a frame rate to
slow down it's the too much lazy
development behind the scenes okay
developers got it no lazy developers as
well um lazy i'm the ultimate lazy
developer no qa the um i've always said
humans were released
your brain is basically constantly
processing information if the
information you're presented with is
stuff you already know or you've already
experienced it happens very quickly it's
just groked and got out the system if
it's something that's novel and
interesting then it takes your brain a
little bit longer to go over it and the
car and the idea is that
our perception of time is tied to that
speed so basically how fast our brains
are working so the more novel
experiences you have in your day the
longer that day's going to feel and
actually the second someone said that to
me i was like yes that completely tracks
with every
because when you're
when you're on holiday somewhere
the time passes very slowly well i think
it's for me it passes quite slowly
because it's like new data new
information
and but then when you're working an
office job where you're doing the same
thing day in day out
in the moment it's boring which makes it
feel slower but when you remember back
to it a year passes in a blink or night
like i think that's the thing is i can
remember like what i did the third day
of a holiday ten years ago but i can't
remember
what you know two years i spent selling
fax machines but wouldn't that be
because you don't identify those
memories as being valuable and thus
you're not trying to retain those that's
the question yeah if it's a story if
it's a if it's something that happens at
the point of story or it's a point
memory your brain going over the hard
drives like me
i will say like definitely i noticed it
like it felt like time
uh went very fast during kind of during
the cove lockdown stuff where i was
literally the same day
and then when i moved house and i had
like new experiences every day and a new
new surroundings everything suddenly the
clock felt like it slowed down again i
feel the opposite i think that when i
have an interesting day it goes fast and
when i have a boring day it goes slow
really yeah okay is that because of the
repetitiveness
the repetition of the day or is that
because of i would think because if you
have a boring day you're actively aware
of the day being boring and thus looking
at the clock more or whatever it's like
sitting
you're not in a flow state basically is
what you're saying you're kind of you're
yeah
that's fast i do believe that is all
that does all track with the kind of
psychological research but i think the
the neuroscience of what you're saying
mike is definitely the prevailing
belief and that was the big thrust of
what this video was watching was about
did i get that right i was really i was
yeah
no no they were saying like obviously
the younger you are the more to the
human experience is novel like just in
general the odds of at age 12 the odds
of something being new
given any random experience is a lot
higher than that same experience to a 30
year old or a 50 year old and so time
you you just don't retain
memories
you know without other intervening
factors like oh it was a you know it was
it was really
it's something that makes it novel which
basically takes us right back to square
one like oh it was you know this 20
millionth time i ate a cheeseburger but
i
i proposed while i was eating it you
know like now it's novel and so that
that is that is sort of because we're
not actually hard drives like we don't
we don't actually store
data we basically build associations um
and neural pathways are just about
linking a to b and if if something
you know resembles a thousand other
things like it we don't we don't hang on
there's no reason to so you're saying
time and of religious cults death loop
troy you have released
i had the perfect doubt i was like it
sounds to me like the answers to
experience new things
like playing death loop
you do have to go though do you have
anything to say before you leave um
nothing of merit
[Laughter]
and the comments will agree by the way
most likely
uh shout out to everybody who uh who did
comment um this week i had some great
conversations man everybody even the bad
this is something that i took from my
friend mike biffle you might be familiar
with them money bikes money bags uh beth
winning bags bike
money bags noted money bags socialist
yeah yeah business owner socialist mike
bethel
[Music]
all criticism is is actionable all
criticism is beneficial so even if you
were someone who
said how much you hate our conversations
i just want to let you know i personally
appreciate you
uh and and thank you for staying there
with a couple i just wish it had time
stamps
i i'm actually paying someone i'm paying
someone to add timestamps now we created
jobs there's people that was like hey
here's the timestamp like the fourth
comment down i'm literally paying
someone to do it so you can all shut
your mouth that's right well then thank
you to that person for doing that that
is just an advert for that feature i
hope you enjoy it everywhere there's all
the
intentions
for the show
um but no thank you for the people that
i had some conversations with uh uh in
in the comments i know that all of us
read read the comments sometimes i know
mike commented on austin loves to do his
comments on saturdays
um that's my saturday morning ritual
yeah coffee so so thank you guys this
has been it's been very beneficial for
me it's been very enlightening for me um
and i'm just making sure that i'm going
to open season to just tear him tear
them up
i feel like most of them were very
excited
between jobs look at this goddamn beer
most of them are very respectful and i
do appreciate our audience for that too
even if they disagree they tend to come
from a place of respect unless we we
talk about cyberpunk it's definitely
always my favorite when someone like new
wanders in and is like why won't they
stay on top of this moderator
we are the moderators we're just shitty
at it i'll play death loop this is
responsible yeah please dude
mike have you played it
definitely yes if you played more of it
god yeah yeah yeah what do you think
i've not completed it i've not completed
i'm
i'm a
i'm enough in the death line for you
right now
i've i've yet to i've not i've i've i've
definitely like killed some important
people i'll play that way i've played i
played through enough for that to have
happened but that wouldn't even be a
spoiler though because you have to kill
the important people like
a million times
yeah which i love i was like genuinely
surprised i thought there was going to
be let's just jump straight into it i
was surprised by how easy to kill a lot
of the batteries super easy to kill
i thought that the child and obviously
the challenge you're building towards is
being able to do the one perfect loop
right but like the um
yeah it's been fascinating
i saw a lot of conversations about this
and i remember the first video i made
you could argue that the ai and death
loop is bad you could you could make a
case for it being bad um in that i
multiple times have managed to clear out
an entire level you can shoot everybody
um they'll forget where you are really
quickly they have very bad cones of
vision
but that's because even though you can
play it like a first person shooter and
you can have those like boss fights
where you just shoot someone with your
nice sparkly shotgun
none of that is the actual challenge of
the game and it would just be annoying
if they made the ai really aggressive or
really smart or you know
overly you from exploring yeah because
the point of it is the puzzle so yeah
you can walk in and you can kill three
of them in a day really easy no stress
and be like cool i did it but it
actually serves you nothing because you
haven't figured out how that helps you
solve the the entire puzzle and doing
the tie-in loop and one or killing
everyone in one loop
which i think is really interesting it's
great
i'm enjoying uncovering that information
it's a really good couple's game which i
was surprised by like it's one of those
ones that i can sit there's a puzzle
play with carrie because it's a puzzle
like that's the thing is i can i'm
enjoying a shooter stealth game but
she's keeping an eye on all of the
bigger picture puzzle stuff so she's
she's playing over a din while i'm
playing that's a good match actually
yeah it kind of works um i was surprised
by that i was surprised by that yeah
the the obra den is actually not that
dissimilar to death leap i feel like
it's closer and obviously like out of
wilds is another fantastic
time loop game and i keep uh i've
downloaded it but i haven't played it
yet because i'm trying to get through a
backlog but um the forgotten city
the um i need to play that everyone
keeps talking to me about that one yeah
based on uh
a very extensive skyrim mod that then
became its own game and came out and has
now won a bunch of awards and it's
supposed to be pretty quick as well
which i love about all these games super
bunny hops review of it just like
completely sold have you watched super
bunny hop i couldn't do that it seems
like a youtube channel
it's definitely yeah he makes really
thoughtful reviews he's really good but
he yeah he he basically sold me on the
game with one of his videos so i do need
to check that out yeah i've definitely
been meaning to but um death loop is
only about 15 hours to finish i guess it
would depend on what you want to do and
how much you want to grind and i
particularly love the way that they tie
the entire narrative into grinding
grinding often just you know in in a
story dream game in a final fantasy
feels like he is this stupid thing that
i have to do that is an aside out of the
run time yeah that takes me away from
this this narrative that that is not
one-to-one and i don't love that um that
that separation whereas in death loop
you grinding is intentionally resetting
the loop so that you can get better [ __ ]
and it it works the mechanic's just so
smart it's just so [ __ ] smart it is
it's really small they're advising the
mechanics so many challenges that to me
is like
be curious if you agree with this mic as
someone who thinks
more through this lens than i do but it
seems like narrativizing those kinds of
mechanics is sort of
one of the next big areas that i think
will mark a kind of maturing of games
where it used to be
you know the mechanics and the story
sat alongside each other if not overtly
kind of contradicted each other you know
where like the tone of the mechanics
like it's a shooter but it's a murder
mystery for some reason you know like
especially i think of a lot of games in
the 90s that where they
they they wanted to tell this story come
hell or high water even though what you
actually did how you actually interacted
with the software seemed to be at odds
with that and we're seeing
less and less and less and less and less
and less of that like to me you know
haiti's overtly narrativizing
its roguelike structure i think it's in
a goal yeah i think that that is what
what we are moving towards that is that
is an idea no one's ever gonna dislike
it
yeah writers game power that's the
fundamental i think that's the root
cause of all of this like and they're in
there from the beginning or they're in
there from the beginning they're often
studio owners not at every stage at
least high up in the car
not at every studio do you not own not
every studio
but when i think about but when i think
about like when if i think if the
average person watching this video and
you should do this in the comments it'll
help the
bots like us but like if you were to
post up your five the five games you
would use as examples of like good
storytelling austin you tried like you
just mentioned hades hades uh greg
kassevin is like i i don't know if he's
uh if he's technically a co-owner but
he's definitely high up in the structure
of that company he's a founder
he's gonna say i'm pretty sure he he
i think yeah yeah yeah so but but then
you know uh people often point to
naughty dog again like writers i mean
santa monica studio though the writers
definitely are considered very important
and i think that's the thing i've
maintained i've probably said this on
the show before but i think
you know often people point to indie
games as being great story-wise i
genuinely think the biggest reason for
that is consistency is is we're not
necessarily telling better stories than
triple a and indeed but i think we're we
have writers better place to tell a
consistent story because they don't have
to work for smaller teams like a very
complex structure and smaller teams so
that consistency can be consistency is
so much more important than innovative
showing off in storytelling one thinks
of a recent indie game that did where it
was like clearly trying to be clever
yeah 12 minutes i felt like that was
something they were definitely doing
they were trying to innovate but they
didn't get the fundamentals of like a
compelling interesting mystery story
kind of in place from from my
perspective as a player so i think that
i think consistency and straightforward
good storytelling goes a long way and
then the barriers to indies doing that
are lower than triple a plus also just
the the non-separation of of the fact
that you're the vessel through which you
tell your story being the mechanics
themselves that this is one of those
things that i learned
just by being a fly on the wall with
that game company while they made
journey like there is no writer on
journey because
in so far as there's no dialogue and
there's no there's no writing in by that
lens but the story of that game is told
by how you
maneuver the environment it's not a
means to an end you know it is it is the
game itself is the narrative
and that was such a
eye-opening experience to watch them
kind of
work that out and figure out you know in
and any mechanic that felt
superfluous to that you know they like
oh well what if we added this thing
where you can do this and that that
might
make this section feel more exciting as
a nice little thing but it's like but is
that telling the story is that actually
you know pushing us forward again i
always go back to uh wiley outside of
journey but i always go back to um the
first bioshock where i i felt like
ken levine kind of
he kind of like broke all shooters
forever uh with the narrative twist in
bioshock because it it it made the game
make so much sense it it
added a narrative credibility to
everything in a way that all
simultaneously undermined the
credibility of all other shooters that
don't have that twist basically i liked
his version of that twist i liked the
the 10 games that ripped off that twist
a bit less yeah there were definitely a
lot of games then they came out that
were like you shot people in the shooter
you're a bad i don't know how many times
i've said this on this channel but ken
levine
is the one who says that he thinks
bioshock is just half-life re-skinned
because yes the the that one little
piece of
writing narrative thing completely
changes it does change it contextually
but it still like plays out in a very
very similar way and i mean to this
obviously i can't say very much about
this but i was really surprised by
probably the thing that surprised me the
most about joining santa monica studio
uh was
how much design the writers do and how
much my job is designed like i'm very
very surprised by that and then you go
and you work with designers so that
there's like an ongoing partnership of
you know figuring out what things look
like and how they play and how mechanics
work i'm i'm not just and that's not
what it is character i i totally have to
think about everything
when i first started in the industry
like you would make a game
and the designer who'd never written
anything would come up with a story
based on whichever movie they'd seen
that week
and then through the process of making
the game you'd have to like delete two
of the levels because they were you know
too expensive to make so you lose your
your narrative beats that were tied to
those levels and then you'd panic about
three months before release and hire a
writer to fix it yeah and that was
genuinely the way it was done for years
and this still is done like that some
studios in fairness but like there's
definitely
there's definitely respect i think the
other thing that i think does dovetail
with this
is um it's kind of is tied to how
journey tells the story also tied to how
um thomas was alone the toilet story
back in the day like these are not games
that are trying to emulate movies like i
don't have a favorite cut scene in death
loop i don't have it i don't have all of
this we we we've stopped this cinematic
thing this desire to make something that
feels like a movie
is fading in popularity and i do think
that's part of it like something like
death loop would break if you put cut
scenes in it because those cut scenes
would seem gross
i was just gonna say that as a lifelong
fan of tim schaefer and as someone who
backed it on fig and all that stuff i
found myself feeling restless during the
opening cutscene because i was like this
is really long but there are also just
cutscenes all the time in that game i
mean i love that game i think it's
fantastic it it what it it makes me feel
like a kid i kept having the thought if
i were a kid i would enjoy this and then
i was like no no i am enjoying this like
i'm a kid this is a great time ergo i am
a kid yeah it's wonderful i'll take that
but there are
so many
stops to have a cut scene where i'm like
should there not have been a room here
where i i know it's complicated well you
could have brainstormed how this could
be interactive how you could tell me
this information while still letting me
levitate around the room because that's
the thing that raz would do anyway you
know like could we still not have a way
to keep the player in this room but also
keep them engaged at the same time and
it it's definitely a thing that i don't
want the games that play as gameplay and
then cutscene to disappear i don't think
that that should go away completely but
i do think games are so much cooler than
that and the technology that we have in
front of us is so much cooler than that
that i would love to see games that are
just gameplay
and that don't get i think we evolve all
the time there's a really interesting
turn of phrase you use there i'm not
picking on you for using the phrase
because it's definitely like something
that i've that people said for a while
i remember with half-life uh two and a
half life one to a less extent but
definitely with half-life two the room
where you were locked in the room while
story happened that you were like this
is just a cut scene but you can jump
yeah you try i don't think that's a
solution you can jump around you can
move around and that was cool but what's
exciting to me is i genuinely think
we've moved even past that point because
when in death are you being held in a
room like you're not there's a that's
the like i i think that's the i think
what you're describing basically i think
i think you're being too nice i think
what you're describing is the bare
minimum like for nowadays for playing to
me it's going further and now we're just
now we're embedding story in
in our world
doesn't have a lot of cutscenes
it has none basically after like it has
a couple of key moments but like yeah
that's great that's what i'm saying is
it's it's embedded you're not the worst
you ever have is like listening to an
audio diary but you can move around and
carry on playing the game while the
audio diary is happening you know it's
great there's obviously no shortage of
cutscenes um in
the new god of war from a couple years
ago but i to that exact point the riding
around on the boat um and all the
kratos atreus interactions that would
happen while you're going location to
location and the the way that it would
never break you know whether the way it
would the no cut camera i do think it
helps well that yeah but that kind of
fakes gameplay in a way that i like like
that kind of
makes you feel like you're not giving up
control
perspective rather than you just
watching two people it's a clever trick
we're at the point now where the cut
scenes have to look like gameplay to be
accepted like it's come full circle and
that's really interesting it also is i
wouldn't say it's a clever trick it was
really hard for them to do that like it
was so complicated everything
i didn't mean to diminish the team like
everything video it is a trick
yeah it makes you feel like you don't
lose control of something and again i
don't want those games to disappear like
to your point austin about bioshock
changing or uh almost invalidating every
other shooter that didn't do that and
still made you do stupid fetch quests um
i feel like the thing that i respect the
most about the last of us part two is
how
by the end of that game i was like this
this is still going i'm exhausted this
is so tedious but i realized that it was
because that's exactly how the
characters felt in that moment that that
entire drag they made me feel the same
way that the characters felt and i was
like so impressed by how one to one that
parallel is that you're like oh my god i
can't believe we have to do this again
and then the more i think about it is
the reflection is that's exactly how
they felt
i do think that that in in that instance
i absolutely think naughty dog did that
intentionally
and it's like i agree just making you
feel that way is so so smart and and
very very difficult that you're like
this is exactly how every [ __ ] piece
of this every single person involved
feels is the way that i feel about it
and i love that one was also parallel
it was so single-mindedly invested in
the in the arc of its characters and it
was so deeply kind of psychological in
nature and just this sort of
really messy and the best sense
exploration of the cycles of violence
and all that sort of thing that
that's one of the only games i can think
of in the last decade where you know
nine hours or something i think it has
of cut scenes yeah it's a lot and i did
not feel i never felt like i want to i
you know give me give me back the st it
really felt organic to the story they
were telling i would have thought
psychonauts two had nine hours of
cutscenes i would not have thought that
the last of his part two did nor would
you think that god of war and i might be
making that number up which i think i
got about 2018's like two or three hours
of
actual cutscenes i don't think it's that
many i could be i could be wrong about
that but it's hard to gauge in that one
because they india they integrate so
seamlessly that sometimes you don't
register to mike's point
it never feels like a cut scene because
it's 10 seconds long it feels like it's
so belongs
the other thing with death loop if we're
talking story that i love which i wish
more games did and again like not to
over reference my own work but thomas
was alone this was definitely something
we got good kind of reviews for
is the characters in the game have
powers that are related to their
personalities in the script and that
level of integration should just be the
norm like if you like it's it's so
standard in like movies novels you know
if a character coughs in the opening
scene of a movie you know they're dying
midway through you know you've got like
there's all of these things which which
you as an audience member even not aware
of the picking up on but death loop has
it right like it has like the nerdy guy
who you know is is uncomfortable in
himself can go invisible and the you
know and all of those
comments reflect them and that's the
thing i also really like in video games
that i i would like to see evolve more
is
you know it wouldn't they lean a little
heavy on the graffiti storytelling
that's definitely feels
weirdly of 10 years ago
that does feel very biased actually um
but i mean like yes but so yeah you know
that's the thing about dying like two
that i've been interested in the thing
about ken levine's game that i've been
interested in is how
player interaction can shape a recurring
environment so a place that you
repeatedly go back to how what you've
done previously can change the way that
certain npcs or people in positions of
power in the example of death loop how
it would change where they exist so that
you feel like you've had an impact on
the environment as well and not just on
this linear story and so that that
pertains to what order you did things in
it wouldn't make sense in deathly
because they are reliving the same day
and they don't know that they're doing
that i guess some of them do but
you won't get into that in any case but
like the idea that you know i could
choose to do something that another
player wouldn't do and then something is
going to be green or something's going
to be flooded and then that is like a
consistent
perception right
like it's much cheaper but you could do
it just your perception shifts that's
the thing though i i think def loops
really good at this where you'll go into
an environment for the first time and it
will look like one kind of environment
and then when you've gone around and
you've learned more about the characters
and you have that space you go through
that it's like going back to your
hometown as an adult and being like wow
this is not this is this was all so much
bigger before you know i think that's
the kind of that's also why it's
definitely cheaper for development teams
to do that kind of thing like it's but
it requires much more talent and skill
on the part of the artist kind of
putting it together so i i think that's
cool as well and that richness i think
that's the thing that death loop does
really well that like i admire in like
the most in the recent hitman trilogy
this kind of
making revisiting a space
imbue that space with more meaning uh
provide you with new challenges
not feel like repeated content which is
what it is right like it's the epitome
of lazy developer to make a triple a
game with four levels
but it doesn't feel that way because
they get so much value out of that space
and you're
you get more value out because you've
been there before and you have a
relationship with an understanding of
that space they just it elevates
everything it's you know what i'm very
very cool one of my absolute favorite
examples of that which is something i
would have brought up despite
uh or i should say irrespective of my
background here today
but um one of the things that for me
absolutely
made mass effect 3 the
the grand champion of that i know that
two is
almost universally people's favorite but
three will will has always been my
favorite and one of the reasons why is
that you
you have to constantly go back to the
citadel and it's the same you know
dozen or so rooms connected through you
know fast travel basically
um but because it's the
a you know it's the destination for all
of the refugees trying to escape this
massive cataclysmic
you know apocalyptic war going on every
time you go back at least after one of
the major story missions
it's more full of people who are like
homeless and don't know what to do and
they add all these extra layers of
background vocals of people you know
saying like have you seen my daughter we
we came together but i can't find her
and it just that feeling of dread and
desperation just gets more and they've
got a wall of missing persons that's
blank at the beginning of the game and
then just becomes this flood of photos
by the end and it's to me that
the fact that that space is seemingly
alive it is the same
it's the same space but there's
something that feels so broken by
comparison and like the first one when
you you go back and like you've done all
this crazy [ __ ] you've traveled the
whole galaxy to go back and like the
same person is standing there drinking
their coffee looking at the fountain on
the presidium like
limitations to development i have total
sympathy for that i i would not
criticize that but i just love that they
managed to outflank that problem so
elegantly and in a way that's so driven
by the narrative and the third one is
just funnily enough it's a bioshock
problem you can follow an npc and then
they'll just sit on the same bench for
the rest of the game
which when you're supposed to be in this
like cultish utopia like does feel very
out of place in bioshock infinite
specifically
they're making the bet that you won't do
that of course but that's it's still
like i think that's something that we're
we again like as game developers we're
only just starting to scratch because
we're finally stopping trying to make
movies in like your classic kind of
hero's journey story
the the feeling you're talking about
austin of like the world changed around
the protagonist of the story that's a
beat that's like that's you're meant to
have a bit at the end of the story where
the character looks around and goes wow
the world's change i've changed but i've
outgrown the world around me and maybe
i've influenced it but ultimately like
it's completely different that's why
you've got to go back to hobbiton at the
end of uh lord of the rings it's why
you've got to have the scene where the
characters uh hang out in vegas after
ocean's eleven you've gotta have that
moment where everyone breathes and goes
wow we really god damn it we've been
through a story here haven't we and
what's amazing with games because
they're geographical because they are
about spaces and about returning to
spaces sometimes you can have that beat
happen
10 times in your story if you had a
movie where if you were making all the
rings and frodo goes back home
you know between missions
and it's and he's keeps he keeps going
back to keeps visiting the mark the
market that upgrade his gear
hear me like what the [ __ ] movie am i
watching
you can do that kind of
but in a video game you can do that and
it's and it won't diminish because your
audience is also not playing it all in
one sitting there's that's the other
thing is like tv show type uh
pacing and storytelling's completely
different again i think definitely games
slowly you'd have trouble i think death
flip is the kind of game that you
probably do need to play
you know that 15 hours or so it is to
finish in two three weeks i think that
you'd have trouble if it if you've seen
that the number one reason i didn't play
by
the time of this call by the way because
when you said
give it
that first time you sit down play for
like four or five hours i haven't had
four or five hours since you said that
to to
solely devote to one
yeah i still recommend doing that yeah
you just have to get past i hope that
doesn't end up being one of those things
that years from now i'm like i'm still
looking forward to death
it's me it's it's me and last of us two
for uh second half i i think there's
i still get messages about that like
most weeks um but the the um
the other thing i think death loop does
really well just to bring it to the
design a little bit
and you've and this is one of the great
things you can see when you think when
you when you have like iconic studios
and you have kind of a franchise or a
legacy and the arcane style of level
design obviously has been through the
through the process a lot of times
death loop definitely feels like from
the ground up it's designed to encourage
you to take a chance and to explore its
systems in a way that none of the others
are you know if you put someone new in
front of
uh dishonored they'll be impressed by
the art of it but at the same time
overwhelmed completely by all the
options yeah and they'll maybe play in a
way that they've played
most people go into it into it
you die and you'd fail
or you just fail and get and death loop
feels so like
brilliantly targeted to that specific
criticism of arcane games of like
go for it try something see how it works
out give it give it a hug to the extent
that it's even i think early on it tells
you not to play it still like a stealth
game like to to try things and
definitely the powers are encouraging
you to play
everything about it is about uh trying
to encourage you to use its systems with
variety
which is so cool yeah it definitely the
powers are actually more stealthy than
they probably should be realistically
they're the most stealthy part of the
that's true but i don't i definitely
gravitate towards those powers as well
just because i love this game so i don't
know if it's just what i've unlocked i
mean i actually do even though i don't
need to often play death loop as a
stealth game even if i don't feel like i
need to and i'm aware that i can kill
everyone i do tend to do that but i was
always that person too
deus ex to me as a like shooter never
my brain just could not comprehend it'd
be the fifth time i played through that
game and i because i played the original
back in 2000 or so i played that game
like 10 times start to finish i just was
upset i didn't get the rocket launcher
battery park never i it's funny even
even having played you know where it's
like okay i can go to that person and
get the password if i just talk to them
and then my tranquilizer
crossbow on that person i had it all
memorized and you'd think there'd be
this temptation what if i just blow the
front door off with my rocket launcher
the game is encouraging me to have that
flexibility it is that's the sales pitch
of that game but i just the the allure
of crawling through those events and
[ __ ] just i couldn't i couldn't escape
it it was it was
yeah
you did remind me of the best trophy in
in death proof which is the
first proof is a movie
because i say death yeah i rewatched
that recently that film is not great um
big tarantino fan that film nothing best
uh
isn't it isn't it like an anthology
movie that's not really a feature
feature i thought
well it's i mean it's feature length but
yeah it was done as a double bill with
planet terror right which is which was a
more fun movie yeah um
but no the sorry this this game that
we're talking about um they i've
completely forgotten what i was going to
say [ __ ]
i've lost my trophy your favorite trophy
oh my favorite trophy which is yeah the
first keypad did you get that one alana
if you try and put in the right coat
yeah i love that it's very good maybe so
also the the fact that the uh the codes
are
generated for every player to be
different so nobody can look it up very
fast i didn't know that that's fun the
thing that i don't feel like many games
have done that everyone kind of should
do but um that is we're out of time look
at us talking about death we spoke about
video games you guys have stuff around
we did it
but now troy had to leave but other than
that
um
so i guess i can't intro the show
probably without troy baker but hi
everyone i'm alana i'm a video game
writer that's my pickle he's a video
shepherd can be uh trophy that's troy
baker
it's a great monster helmet and that is
austin wintry he is a video game so
we'll see you guys next week bye